so okay it was three I had the number
three written down I was just looking in
the main hall three coming up
challenge five minute here we go let's
do it
27 27 alright let's try this one more
time
there's no way I could lose two games in
a row right that's impossible or very
possible it's very possible so let's run
with this try and pick up the pace okay
that right there I believe is considered
to be the best right that's gonna be the
best move to be running with why is that
the case can anybody answer that I see
through the best that I think it's it's
a good move to be running with to just
kind of wait on those little waiting
games
so this alright we're just doing a
little bit of dancing here and yeah
there's nothing really exciting about
this in fact I don't know I think this
is like maybe like a what they just kind
of have to go back eventually because
what are the alternatives
Bishop goes to d3 I could actually
consider Bishop to h3 right so I don't
know what's the big idea here
what are whites candidate moves anybody
now oh my phone is talking to me all
right he's got it they were trying to
meet the stream so they weren't going
into a deep think so now if I win this
it's because they were trying to mute
their stream and they burned like an
hour trying to figure it all out
okay back to doing some chess I'm gonna
go here kind of breaking this pin a bit
right and I'm gonna out for a clean
exchange actually could we have a clean
exchange is that possible
or no Queen exchange Queen takes Queen
Knight takes Queen are we gonna be
seeing c4 no okay the ladies are off so
now what okay I think this is a good
approach because you'll note my
resulting pawn structure it's on light
squares and my bishop gets off the board
then it's gonna work well all right my
remaining pawn structure should be
pretty good let's come back here if I
don't have my lights croquet let's go
with this and no what am I gonna be in
some trouble here
might I be in some trouble are they
gonna allow me to get off their light
square bishop okay now so that was a
pretty interesting one right there
I wasn't really expecting that so now
what to do with this Knight he's a
little bit of a pain here so let's try
and put at least some pressure on him
now typically in the caro-kann what is
it that you would like to do I think for
the most part having
I think this is an important move to be
running with I could be wrong because
now c6 is um there's some issues with c6
so let's do this watch out for g4 and
next up I believe King here because I
have to anticipate the night playing
here and I want to be able to take him
out so what next this I don't have to
worry about
I think getting my rook here is a good
idea I don't have to worry about I'm in
a pin but is there really any issues I'm
thinking about b5 here
now that this rook is no longer on the a
file I'd be able to get that in with
some success
maybe rook here first b5 pawn takes pawn
takes if the knight moves I'm gonna go
here first I'm missing anything I'm not
sure um oh you know what I forgot to do
I forgot to do something here okay so
that's actually over that's a really
strongly place tonight right there
alright I forgot to do something usually
when i stream I I do some other stuff
but I forgot to do that um so that
Knight is uh well you know what it's
coming out and down to right here I
don't really have a constructive plan at
this point I don't think let's just play
here maybe I could actually meet
something like a knight here with like
backing my bishop up wanna be cautious
that my knight doesn't get trapped as
well I think there's might be something
slick my opponent could be doing with
like rook backing up 93 chased my rook
away and then grab this guy that's what
being threatened I believe let's get out
of that night there could have been a
strong when hitting my rook and
essentially my pawn because I'm still in
that pin so my rook might actually be
I don't know okay they're prepping this
particular move and how should I deal
with that I'm gonna back up actually
maybe I could be playing a c5 in some
instances might want to just coordinate
my pieces a little bit better too there
might actually be a pretty good response
I don't want my rook here in fact it's -
I think it's a bit too accessible so
let's just get it back here where it's
kind of everything is a bit more
protected and now maybe
c5 c5 huh
this is tough because this pawn is ready
to push well I play here maybe I want to
get c5 in or something in fact you know
maybe oh no what
okay I'm gonna back up again
guard this pawn may be like if okay I
kind of have to run with that done I and
let's try this maybe I could get my
Bishop there to recapture and I think
this is a good spot for my bishop if I'm
not mistaken right could be wrong
definitely be wrong and I think I want
to keep a close eye on this pawn break
so and I wanna I wanted to go here with
this so that that move doesn't come with
threats and actually there's a lot of
fire actually the Knights being hit and
actually I could take here with check um
should I insert that particular move I
think it's good to do that let's do this
first
and I do you want to watch out for what
oh okay I think I'm just better at this
point if I'm not mistaken let's go here
and then double up
I'm just winning upon and then getting
ready to push away
hmm let's try this and then looking to
maybe double up on their seventh rank um
I don't think there's much more
excitement in this game I think I might
want to offer a draw I'm now for a draw
my opponent does have fewer time as well
I don't know that there's really much to
do here
are we just gonna have it drop I have
three pounds they have to they're a
little bit down on time and they're
offering me a drawback so I think that's
a reasonable result good game seeing
just backing up okay caro-kann let's get
some c3 once there just say here with c3
it kind of it's like a little bit of a
waiting type of move right like they
want to see where my they don't want to
develop their night so well wait let me
back up how to uh okay let me back up I
need to formulate these thoughts
accurately right here to describe what I
mean because this isn't like this isn't
like this isn't so easy to describe
maybe well what is it that black wants
to do black wants to get their Bishop
out and this is you you might as well
chalk this up this is an ID you want to
run forward with in any caro-kann you
want to get your light-square bishop
outside of your pawn chain and then play
e6 so knowing this knowing this right
now if white just goes casually with
Knight seat Knight f3 excuse me
even though that that is a move you know
I I have an additional option of just
coming immediately out to g4 however by
playing c3 it supports the center and
now it's like well what do I do in the
meantime do I play to f5 I certainly
can't elated g4 it's really limiting my
responses so Bishop f5 the knight then
comes out and now they're not having to
deal with the pin if they do be able to
pin then it only comes up well it's
coming at the cost of what at the cost
of me having to make two moves before
I'm there
so this right here this is a little
whatever I don't even know what you call
if white really wants it turns out to be
a draw and they just kind of shuffle
back and forth but I knew why it
wouldn't be wanting him draw because
they're playing the white side but
anyhow that we really got into this
quick endgame and this right here we're
really shocked me I didn't I don't know
but it's just kind of going into a lot
pretty a pretty what a pretty balanced
endgame and I know what what the main
thing I'm not going to be going over all
the moves but I'm just trying to be I'm
a bit general I'm trying to take into
account what the potential pawn breaks
might be at this point so
I'm preparing to meet like a five with B
five I'm trying to prepare B 5 with
maybe C 5 that's one reason why I'm
playing my trip to see a etc one a
little trick right here I saw that that
might be coming up and I hear hitting
both of those guys but pretty dry
position at the end of it I was up upon
but there's not really much she could
really do to advance it I don't think
right if anything I could be playing
maybe for a win here but it's it's not
happening this rook just keeps a close
eye on either my king or my pawn
etcetera so it's a it's a fairy zone
right there